so this scene was just absolutely brutal
so Raymond calls rhaenyra's son's
bastards and also calls her a [ __ ] to
which the king responds with
half your time and before you know it
Damon just slashes his head in half of
his sword now unfortunately I don't
think this is the scene I can show on
YouTube but it was just absolutely
brutal and this just came out of nowhere
I was not expecting this at all and it
did leave me quite shocked everyone in
the crowd here is just absolutely
shocked at what happened we then see the
remains of Raymond as the camera pans up
to Damon as he says he can keep his
tongue which was quite a snarky comment
from Damon we then cut to Eamonn who was
smiling as he watches Damon where he
looks quite impressed at what he just
saw now I haven't read the books but it
looks like a little bit of foreshadowing
here of Eamon wanting to be more like
Damon so perhaps he's getting some ideas
of his own here and wants him to
implement more of what Damon does to
himself but that pretty much summarizes
this scene so let me know what you guys
thought of this episode and seen in the
comment section below and if you did
enjoy and you're new to the Channel
please consider subscribing and turning
the notifications on thanks for watching
guys